ce
oh
sotra
alors non
parce que
fin
je fais boulanger artisan depuis 30 ans
dans un petit village breton de la
technique me signale je ne sais quoi
dans un petit doigt dans un petit
village breton de 300 habitants c'est à
qui vit dans le morbihan tout près de
brocéliande entendu parler ouais voilà
la fourrer m'envoie et donc mais je suis
né à côté à pannecé qui vient du latin
panne et c'est qui veut dire par ici et
le pain et une autre bourgade dans le
monde a la même étymologie c'est
bethléem
la maison du pain et je vais donc
arrêter là les comparaisons je travaille
deux jours par semaine le mardi et le
vendredi
mars vénus vous avez compris je prends
deux mois de vacances l'été encore
quinze jours à noël un et j'ai une femme
qui travaille à quart de temps et nous
avons élevé trois enfants construit
plein de petites maisons
un grand jardin des poules et des
moutons et voilà demi autarcie et malgré
tout cependant une grande abondance
voilà et c'est justement cette situation
qui a créé quelques suspicions parmi les
villageois
la maison est entourée de chanel dans
les bois et j'étais accusé
une joie de trafic de gland voilà l'anc
est conclu à un non-lieu trafic de
gaulle en évidemment pour nourrir les
cochons parce que vous savez qu'en
bretagne
il y a plus de cochons et d'un don que
deux bretons donc une eau polluée
évidemment une eau polluée
c'est pourquoi je fais mon pain à
l'autre puis ils ont du ciel voilà la
seule encore potable aujourd'hui
vérifiés par les analyses
donc le chant que vous avez entendu tout
à l'heure et est un jean une gwerz
bretonne une complainte si on pourrait
dire des années 70 80
qui ou à cette époque nous rêvions d'une
belle société d'un paradis sur terre or
die yanez dns dit le champ misère misère
depuis le monde a dérapé et vous terres
polluées une terre massacrer une terre
défiguré une terre saccagées au
esperanza dit encore le texte le barde
que nous reste-t-il comme espoir encore
aujourd'hui alors pour y répondre mais
j'ai dix ont organisé ma vie autour de 3
attention particulière et la première la
première que je me conseille à moi même
c'est de trouver sa propre locomotive
autrement dit quelles valeurs tirent le
train de notre existence est ce l'argent
cela reconnaissance la gloire le pouvoir
ou le plus souvent la sécurité toutes
ces choses mises devant se termineront
en dépendance j'ai choisi la liberté
et tout ce que je vous ai nommé tout à
l'heure viendront derrière en
conséquence et évidemment en récompense
donc de manière de conduire sa vie
choisir ou subir choisir est une
discipline de de se donner des objectifs
et de s'y tenir ou de terminer les
choses commençaient et c'est assez
fabuleux le contentement d'être en ordre
voilà sinon c'est l'environnement et les
événements qui vont faire qui vont venir
à vous sous forme de contrainte donc
contrainte ou discipline à choisir ou à
subir et autant la discipline c'est un
élan vers la vie autant les contraintes
ce sera un effort toujours permanent or
si l'élan ville l'effort tu et quand
j'étais apprenti puis après ouvrier
boulanger
j'en ai eu beaucoup de patrons parce que
je supportais pour beaucoup les patrons
est beaucoup trop - à l'autorité est
donc alors j'ai changé souvent ils m'ont
tous dit la même chose évidemment vu mon
comportement je pense un délinquant et
donc ont tous dit si tu fais à ta tête
tu seras toujours malheureux je suis
retourné les voir je leur dis depuis que
chama tête ça a beaucoup mieux
deuxième attention que je m'accorde
c'est comment dire deuxième attention
que je m'accorde supprimer tout inutile
dans sa vie toutes les choses qui ne
servent à rien se débarrasser du
superflu et de l'inutile c'était une
grande révélation pour moi quand j'ai
découvert que vendre le pain c'est
autant de temps que de faire le pas
c'est assez étonnant
quelques magasins donc vendre le pain
autant de temps que de faire le pain
alors j'ai donné la caisse aux clients
ils se servent à la sortie du four dans
l'étagère ils prennent la monnaie dans
la caisse
voilà comment dire ils prêts ils font la
commande pour la semaine d'après moi je
suis là je suis pas là souvent je suis
là mais si je suis pas là c'est pareil
eux ils viennent le jour comme la nuit
la veille ou le lendemain la veille a
pas de pain le lendemain il part à 6
mais ça fait rien ils peuvent se servir
quand ils veulent et donc c'est
totalement libre c'est à la fois ma
liberté à moi est celle du client
je suis en micro entreprise et je fais
du pain pour cent cinquante familles 300
à 500 consommateurs
or un boulanger on va dire
conventionnelle lui il faut 2500 clients
pour s'en sortir et pour amortir tous
ces investissements de matériels énormes
de magasins et de et de tout ce qui l a
besoin pour entretenir sont fournis
évidemment moi je n'ai ni comptables ni
informatique et la comptabilité je vais
vous dire vous pouvez venir voir c'est
une demi journée par an au crayon jamais
l'administration de ma fait de reproche
ouais nous voilà mais évidemment pour
les boulangers conventionnel ce serait
travailler avec un petit four comme j'ai
à la main fait tout à la main ce serait
une honte quoi ce serait une honte un
peu comme un paysan qui retourneraient
là chez rue avec un homme hors de cette
honte j'en ai fait une fierté
troisième attention et la dernière et
après je vous donnerai une recette
surprises bonnes recettes de pain non
parce que et 3e attention être amoureux
de tous tout d'autant que projection de
soi autour de nous donc autant choisir
des choses et des êtres que l'on aime et
qui nous plaisent voilà être amoureux de
ses rêves et tram ou retirés de l'enfant
surtout de les retrouver et amoureux de
de son métier de sa voiture de sa maison
et de sachets de sa chemise de sa
chemise a donc voilà ah oui et donc
celle qui m'emmène dans mes voyages
d'été et donc vous l'avez pas vu
derrière aussi alain bauer aussi est
donc cette voiture je les décors et
voilà vous voyez pas tout il ya des
rideaux aussi partout autour il ya un
volant en bois un volant en bois voilà
et donc vous vous rendez compte si
toutes les voitures étaient décorées
comme ça sur la route plutôt que tous
ces clones à se suivre
triste et monotone sur les autoroutes
donc derrière ça qu'est ce qu'il y a il
y a que deux cultivez votre différence à
travers une voiture ou à travers un
t-shirt peuple mais cultiver votre
différence si vous êtes des caricatures
personne ne vous reconnaîtra et si vous
êtes ce que vous êtes à ce moment là
vous serez prêt à répondre aux besoins
de l'autre et il viendra vers vous
alors je sais si cette recette que je
vais vous donner en partir c'est un
cadeau enfin vous l'apprécierez vous
même il peut être un peu ça l'est
peut-être mais la puissance et la voie
la plus paralysante qu'ils soient si on
veut que le monde change ainsi qu'on le
souhaite
quoi or on peut prier et méditer se
révolter ou comment dire manifester tout
mais tout ça sert pas à grand chose
il faut d'abord agir et je vais vous
donner trois gestes qui peuvent changer
le monde ce soir au plus tard demain
matin
c'est accessible à vous tous ici tout à
fait possible c'est très simple et je
vous garantis que si 50% de la rochelle
le fait vous serez une lumière dans le
monde voilà premier geste vous arrêtez
le supermarché vous laissez tomber le
chariot
vous reprenez votre panier vous allez
vous dans votre jardin dans les biocoop
si vous n'avez pas de jardin dans les
marchés locaux et vous trouverez déjà
beaucoup de choses qui éviteront plein
d'emballage plein de camions sur les
routes plein d'exploitation des pays
émergents deuxième geste vous retirez
tout votre argent des banques
conventionnelles et voulait placer dans
des banques alternatives qui ne spécule
pas ya là il ya la nef ya les cigales il
ya tout ça et ce sera terminé des
spéculations financières qui détruisent
notre monde
et justement c'est très proche de votre
circulation sanguine
d'où vient votre argent c'est à dire
comment vous nourrissez où vous mettez
vous où est stockée et qu'en fait vous
comment vous le dépenser votre énergie
le cholestérol n'a rien à voir avec le
beurre c'est tout une histoire de
stockage de sang ça reste calé dans les
artères parce qu'il fait rien là où il
fait où ils empoisonné troisième chose
troisième geste et le dernier sera déjà
pas mal je pourrais vous en citer
d'autres
vous coupez votre compteur électrique du
fournisseur officiel
voilà et vous allez vous abonner à
enercoop et des organismes sa de de
production d'énergies alternatives
renouvelables
et ça viendra par les mêmes tuyaux ça
j'en conviens mais seulement votre
facture vous le paierez plus à qui je
pense mais à d'autres et ça n'ira plus
nourrir les centrales nucléaires si
dangereuse pour toutes les générations
futures
le problème c'est qu'il y a une grosse
résistance et c'est ce qu'on nomme est
certain le l'énigme de l'inaction
pourquoi ne change on ou pas et bien
pour ça c'est une résistance au
changement bien sûr mais c'est aussi une
volonté délibérée de ne pas changer tout
ça vous comprenez très bien ce que ça
veut dire quoi et donc parce que
pourquoi parce que ça atteint en nous
nos sécurités et surtout notre identité
de consommateurs c'est des petites morts
qui attendent la résurrection d'une
autre manière et donc riche de quoi du
coup mais riche de toutes ces
nourritures nouvelles dont j'ai parlé
depuis le début est alors à ce moment là
il s'agira vraiment d'une autre
abondance mais pour ça il faut commencer
par le début
d'abord choisir sa locomotive et bon
voyage